pilot to Bombardier pilot to Bombardier
this clouds are bad
pilot to Bombardier
oh [ __ ]
loading this [ __ ] debt
you bad [ __ ]
you
it's a beautiful day to be alive the
birds are chirping the clouds are out
ten of files have their best t-shirts on
but you don't give a [ __ ] maybe uncle
Joey's back and ready to rock as you
could tell that monster snowstorm turned
out to be [ __ ] nothing so we're back
to square damn [ __ ] normal don't
listen to the [ __ ] white weathermen
they don't know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about just live your [ __ ]
life I'll be sailing in two
[ __ ] Baltimore with the weed
and the crack that killed a why
understand me I'm coming with the
strength of ten [ __ ] savages straight
to ball tomorrow give a [ __ ] Thursday
Friday Saturday Mugu B's [ __ ] and
beside that it's a beautiful day I got
the best me for in town
I got the [ __ ] perennial and I got
this voodoo mix of Russian debt you
understand
but enough with the chitty-chat oh it's
all about you today you understand me
who gives a [ __ ] what the Conservatives
or who gives a [ __ ] with the Liberals
are doing they're all wasting their time
well they're [ __ ] walking around uh
you got your hands up the [ __ ] Mona
Lisa skirt finger-banging in a debt they
understand me and that's the [ __ ]
plan never let them see you come let
them give look at this guy who gives a
[ __ ] uncle Joey's right there barking at
your [ __ ] door like a dog that hasn't
eaten in 10 days and I suggest you put
on the same [ __ ] mentality ain't
nobody stopping you it's Wednesday these
[ __ ] Gentiles are starting to fall
apart at the seams that dilly-dallying
who bugged the White House listen I
don't give a [ __ ] you know I give a [ __ ]
about I got the weight that Nixon smoke
this is this [ __ ] right here perm ready
we're going to finish this I got the
last batch of the evil dose of it I got
it a heathen
they he didn't [ __ ] make it nice and
dry you know why cuz that's how uncle
Joey rose [ __ ] beside that you know
me I got a full schedule already had an
audition this morning I already wrote
this morning I did my morning [ __ ]
stretch this morning I'm a little too
jiu-jitsu I'm gonna spend some time with
my [ __ ] wife and it's over Baltimore
I'm taking the missile of debt right to
you you follow me
and as usual the mule left to [ __ ]
Baltimore on Monday I had him there
daily to avoid the snow he's in a hotel
room with two pounds of weed and the
same [ __ ] that [ __ ] killed I don't
even know anymore there's this [ __ ] they
kill Fidel waiting on me in Baltimore
just cuz I gave up edibles for Lent
don't mean I'm not a [ __ ] Savage no
more makes me more of a [ __ ] Savage
I got hypnotized now I'm ready to rock
and roll you understand me I got some
needle stuck in me this week
acupuncture jujitsu writing I miss focus
I can be you're falling back and
hypnotized a [ __ ] I don't anyway
I'm stoned what do you want from me
people what am i [ __ ] Johnny thesaurus
I got a spin our [ __ ] words here you
know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
wash your [ __ ] be on point write your
goals and don't let nobody [ __ ] with you
that's it those are the three could mean
for [ __ ] things hey what's in here
nothing little guts
little gossip
oh let me tell you something else
tonight midnight I'm on Comedy Central
on Doug Benson's High Court if you want
to see some [ __ ] clouds
you better tune in tonight DVR do
whatever the [ __ ] you got to do tonight
go to local listings High Court Comedy
Central
Doug Benson you're right you're gonna
see [ __ ] clowns you're gonna see
[ __ ] wrong power
there'll be talks about girl power and
guy power and Burson
this is [ __ ] lung power wrapped with
dick and heart you follow me anyway
who's ready for another bowl of death
look at me I'm three sheets to the wind
II think I'm tapping out in the [ __ ]
know everybody else is going with that
door and hanging out trying to be cute
taking pictures for you on Instagram I'm
over here [ __ ] doing wouldn't is
necessary spreading love blowing some
smoke getting rid of your spirit or
smile off and putting it together
dr. police astound the good air blowing
out the hot air you follow me and that's
it the podcast with Chris Porter should
be up this afternoon on YouTube and
iTunes and that said mother flies
I'll see you [ __ ] in Baltimore
or tonight and the High Court with Doug
Benson make sure you tape it right now -
uncle Joey your song I don't ask you for
my glasses - you for a ride to the
airport do I ask you to break your
[ __ ] balls no I actually don't
[ __ ] thing to take this wrong with
Joey
so you'd and I brought my own way this
usually you don't meet Doug I show up
[ __ ] prepared some people show up
with ice cubes and a [ __ ] custard
cake I show up with [ __ ] Riesling
three animals so there's no
misunderstandings
I love you [ __ ] the next time I
see your innocent ally and well I'm the
stage and I'm saying the Sun came over
so the [ __ ] contact was trying to
[ __ ] up we think about the new head I
was like Bela Lugosi before the
operation is [ __ ] but it don't matter
it's all about heart and balls and
that's it you [ __ ] at random
what's the word it don't matter
you're all about hunting balls get out
there swing dick and don't forget about
your uncle Joey I didn't forget about
you [ __ ] have a great day
go out there and [ __ ] impose your
will on these [ __ ] you only live
once uncle Joey's loves you stay black
oh you get that didn't get my might that
I Pindari I said it boy you see they
didn't get my metal I bring a condom on
oh I see a kilo ohm Anita